foreign
Bob is in Minneapolis hey Bob welcome to
the Ramsey Show
hey Dave uh so my question is I came
across this opportunity to buy a
multi-family apartment building cool in
a prime location I'm very tight with my
money and I'm constantly trying to come
up with different ways to make more
money aside from my full-time job as a
licensed electrician the only debt I
have is on my house
with 75 000 more to go
the price of the apartment will range
anywhere from 1 million to 1.5
the bank has approved me and my partner
on this deal and is contingent on the
rent roll
I know you guys like to pay cash for
things and so do I we only have about 10
to 15 percent for a down payment I'm
just an average guy that makes 75 000 a
year
and really want another source of income
do you think this is too much debt to
take on also if you were me how would
you tackle this process if I were to go
through with this deal
uh and we plan on using uh the positive
cash flow to pay down the debt on that
pretty aggressively
a couple things on top of that well I
can stop you okay okay let me just stop
you gave me enough information and
um
here's the thing you've got uh you got
the fever really really bad
and
um I've had the fever how old are you
27 okay
um
I was 28 when I filed bankruptcy from
doing deals like this
exactly like this
and uh this deal is a bad idea it's a
bad idea because you're gonna have a
partner and you don't need a partner
number one it's a bad idea because
you're going to get in trouble with a
partner and he's going to leave and then
you're going to be left holding the
whole bag or he's going to start doing
drugs and you're going to be left doing
the whole bag or he's going to get a
divorce and move to Montana and you're
going to be left holding the whole bag
or whatever happens to stupid but
Partners you're going to learn the hard
way the only ship that won't sell is a
partnership the second thing is that
mathematically when you've leveraged
this thing as high as you've leveraged
it dude you got no wiggle room here if
you get a 20 vacancy this thing will
bankrupt you
it won't carry itself because you got it
won't it won't service the debt you got
you got to keep it completely full and
operating like a maniac for with a 15
down an 85 percent leverage position 85
loan to value you can't keep this thing
cash flowing
um and and so no you're not a buyer for
this this is an opera this is not an
opportunity for you this is a nightmare
uh I don't know if I can talk you out of
it because you've got the fever so bad I
can feel the heat coming off your
forehead
I know I just I feel like I need to do
something you don't yeah you don't but
don't don't do something desperate and
stupid okay because this is this is this
has got so many red flags on it now
someday I want you to own some rental
property that you pay cash for I did
deals like this I own three million
dollars worth and when I was 28 I was
bankrupt with a brand new baby a toddler
and a marriage Hanging On by a thread I
don't want that for you and you're not
just an average guy making 75 000 uh
your God makes seventy five thousand
dollars and you're 27 years old and
you've got the ability to earn some
money build some wealth and own some
paid for real estate in the future and
then it won't own you and you won't have
a partner screwing up your life
and
um uh I don't know if there's any amount
of words I can say while I have you on
the phone to keep you from doing this
but if I could say them I would right
now
um so there is no equation under which
if I were you I would do this
there's you you are your mathematics are
out of whack on this you don't know what
the flip you're doing I own hundreds of
millions of dollars worth of real estate
and believe me you have vacancy you have
legal costs you have people that don't
pay and you have to remove them you have
people that beat their wife and you have
to remove them because they're in jail
you have all this crap that happens when
you own a multi-family like this and oh
and the heat and air goes out and it's
twenty five thousand dollars
and you don't have any money oh and then
the roof starts leaking oh and then
Coach comes by and says oh you know that
way you did the parking lot oh I didn't
do the parking lot the last owner did oh
doesn't matter you got to spend 60 000
bucks redoing that or we're going to
shut the whole freaking place down oh by
the way your light your electric meter
that you've got on this thing it's now
Antiquated and the electrician says he
won't work on it because it's dangerous
oh that's gonna be twenty six thousand
dollars
see this this is the crap that they
don't tell you about when they say your
renters are going to pay it off for you
your renters aren't going to pay it off
for you
you're going to pay it off or you're
going to go bankrupt in the process of
trying to hold on this thing so I hope I
said enough what I'll hold my beer Dave
there's the math consequences here
let me tell you what also is going to
happen you're not going to sleep
you're not going to sleep for years
because that brain that is so desperate
to get an income a second income is also
going to be the same brain that's going
to recognize you are no longer safe you
are no longer in control of your destiny
if you get laid off everything collapses
your relationships are going to suffer
don't do this you're worth more or
you're worth a non-anxious life man and
this is not it